right we're going to accelerate a little
bit so finance find the person I really
really do mean by the time for the
maximum life is so what am I gonna do
with this I don't have any tiny wearing
these equations sorry okay so I'm gonna
rewind and I look we're not going to go
through its the algebra here I'm just
going to run my first line for you so
this is for Patsy yes I'm going to come
back to this this guy over here are
twins right and because now I've got a
different goal want this anymore right
I'm gonna say since our goal is related
to time
ok so once you've are you want time into
play you're fine ok by the way I
actually could have if I wanted to like
I've got to statement in two expressions
of notation that both have time and like
this one enough of this one I really
could have used I bar because I know
about the displacer and I know about the
lawsuit but there's an obvious reason
why she chose this one namely yeah I
went they didn t great wants to make
this useful whereas i'm going to
integrate this twice and it's going to
be another closet i don't have enough
information so this where it's going to
go i will get you let's go i'm going to
give you some of the working okay just
so you can confirm for yourself when you
work this fall out you're going to
eventually get this 50g yeah okay you're
going to get this now don't worry about
that negative 50 lakhs just the cost of
it I can take out if I like look
carefully what family of functions is
just going to integrate up in turn yeah
very good so this tiny difference here
see using beauty dr DX vs using GV on dt
ok you've got a a squared plus x squared
situation ok so after you integrate and
you sort out your constant integration
this is what you should land on this is
what I do think it's square is a 5150
Audrey
oh my god I think this is actually that
sorry cancer you're after you get using
ugh yeah it's not even visible this
should be the capital that was totally
right doesn't that have the vibe of all
of course debtors how nice and neat in
love with okay okay yeah okay now here
I'm just going to comment on the
Reston's because we are we are getting
to that time right um exile it off with
a downward journey okay thinking about
how we define X double dot for the
awkward journey and then thinking what's
going to be different this these are
both going to be different okay these
are both kind of different so I'm going
to let down be positive and I'm going to
choose a new origin as well right so the
park was gone up and then it stops and
I'm going to call that my new origin and
then off it goes so the way i would
start this and maybe you want to write
this now is I'm going to say that down
be positive and 0 v okay what should I
call it's not the point of projection if
the looks of height yeah that's where
I'm that's what I'm going to start off
again right being a maximum height okay
now keep in mind now you remember we
retrieve it off the ground okay in the
first situation where is the ground what
x coordinate what makes times the ground
x equals zero right because that's the
point of projection under this new
scheme where is the ground
now x is gonna be it's going to be a
positive guy because it's below me and
the distance is the magnitude of that is
ok right yeah so the X equal attention
ok so once you do this this is going to
be very soon right what will be
different you have different you have
it- inside for the resistance ok so so
you're getting crabbing right gravity is
always pointing down but I've redefined
down as positive right so this guy how
the front is going to be not maybe your
bungee got 1g what about air resistance
it's so romantic air resistance is still
against it heiresses will always be like
okay so this is going to be take away
0.02 whisper okay and that's gonna be my
my ones
now I've got a question for you do you
want me to comment on these two or just
let me have a go because I can i can
post this up let me just ask you this a
table I'll just comment on you you have
to get impacted it ends up being a
similarly terrible expression like this
very very missable ok I want to ask you
about this this guy here right do you
think you're in taxi will be faster or
the same or slower than your initial
speed I think maybe just get the window
just for the next two
yeah yeah when x equals H just push his
body's way below so yeah yeah yes a real
I haven't finished yet so I just got
this is that yes and border okay now let
me tell you let me tell you what the
answer is and then you can keep up with
the advil I'll give you the intuition
impact speed is less than initial
impacts me is less than initials fear
now I want you to think back to
projectile motion all right projectile
motion think they can see people in
projectile motion deliberately ignored
air resistance and that perfect nice
symmetrical parabolic situation right
your initial speed and your impact fee
were identical right all the speed you
lost on the way up you get it exactly on
the way back down okay now tell me think
think think why is this mean I have to
be slower okay remember when I read this
and when I wrote this right on both the
initial journey and on the return
journey you're losing speed because air
is ready both times slow down the first
time and then you slow down again ok
just a huge amount but it's enough ok so
I don't push that solutions this
afternoon you can go ahead and look at
it you sort of algebra before you look
at it thanks everyone I'll see it's my
boy